I think the very first game that I
played that really made me really start
thinking and looking for ways that games
could do something with a narrative that
nothing else could well I think the
first one that just really made it click
for me was the end of Metal Gear Solid 3
but spoilers after the very end fights
fighting the boss when you have that
long Kadima cutscene and you end up with
the snake standing over the defeated
boss with a gun ready to complete his
mission shoot her in the head do what he
has to do and the camera cuts to that
shot above like kind of above looking
down at this field of flowers and they
took characters standing there and it
just stays there and nothing really
happens and you're kind of waiting for
him to do it and then the button prompts
pops up in the corner of the screen the
or1 pops up that like tells you it's
he's not gonna do it until you pull the
trigger and you've realized that you
have to do it you have to pull the
trigger you're the one who has to do
this thing that you don't want to do and
the character doesn't want to do and
you've had gone on this arc with the
character all along the way of kind of
feeling betrayed by her of really liking
this character of respecting her of not
of not wanting to have to carry out this
mission but here you are at the moment
of truth and you have to do it and he
has to do it neither of you have a
choice and the player and the character
are both brought to this exact same
state of mind and state of feeling so
perfectly and Angele so well that I was
just blown away by it it was just a
really powerful moment and from then on
like that that was the moment that kind
of like just lit the spark of Oh games
can do something really unique here
something that no no other medium can
emulate this than a way that I can think
of and since then I have it is it made
me excited for games in a way I never
had before and
so it i so i thank my lucky us all three
and kijima for all in all his weirdness
for giving me such a for giving me such
a that's just a glimpse into what games
could do I've loved it